I think we maybe have time for one maybe
two more calls we're taking the calls at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 our next caller is
from the 3 8 5 area code caller what's
your name and what's on your mind
hi David can you hear me we can hear you
fine perfect this is how the Robertson
I'm currently from Salt Lake City Utah
my question is this for you I'm
currently a biology student or science
student and I'm wanting to get your
input for someone who's young who's
wanting to enter the political process
I'm only 20 years of age but I was
curious what advice or what exactly
would you suggest for someone who is
wanting to enter politics in a red state
to try and move for more progressive
agenda well I think the you know set
your sights at what is most accessible
right now and that might be you know I
don't know what the government structure
is where you either have residency or
would be able to get involved in the
political process but if you can look
into running as a city councilor
somewhere sometimes those races are I
mean in Western Massachusetts in the
city of Northampton where we started the
show right if if you could put together
400 votes I believe you could become a
city councilor yeah and so there are
places and I'm sure you know some of
these places is well Pat where the
barrier to entry for someone who's
motivated and energetic is not that high
to get into some kind of political or
government position yeah or even these
school counselor positions you can do
that too and being a recent student
yourself you would have a good
perspective and probably elections and
meet a lot of people in that and that uh
arena yeah and can you get involved in
like Student Senate at your University
so on the student at Westminster College
it's small liberal arts school and I'm
actually involved in a process and a few
organizations Democracy Now and a few
others that are trying to bridge party
lines between Republicans and Democrats
so I am currently involved however I was
curious to have your input I've been
watching the show for around two years
now and this is the first time they've
been calling in and I want to get your
input more than APL's
yeah I mean I think certainly you know
look into whether there's a city council
opportunity there's also even if you
can't do that there
appointed positions on commissions right
so they're not elected it's basically
just hey we need four people to serve on
this committee and it's a committee that
includes both members elected officials
and uh lay people for lack of a better
term and we work together and it could
be on a variety of different issues
that's an opportunity depending on the
state you're in you know being a state
representative I mean that crazy
anti-gay former Navy chaplain Gordon
Klingenschmitt he got himself elected to
the Colorado State House for one term
and that seemed incredibly unlikely
David Duke and Louisiana David Duke in
Louisiana yes so I think there's a
number of possibilities if you bring
energy that's an excellent polling and I
know that there are probably other
colors on one but could I ask you one
other question quickly please yes by all
means absolutely I'll be as quick as
possible and then obviously being
assigned student myself the the not the
inability but the lack of general
understanding in any sort of science
field I'm I think the better issue that
we can both agree on would be global
climatic stabilization or for lack of a
better term climate change
what is your in your view and in pass
you the best way to try and ht8 more of
a scientific literacy in the local
community and more broad yeah well so
you're asking more about the broader
thing which is why would anyone be
against dealing with climate change as a
human influence issue given what the
science says and we've talked many times
about how do to elaborate climate change
I'm sorry just a bit not only with
climate change but you look at the gain
not only with climate change but with
stem-cell research with scientific
funding in general and how there's been
just a complete upheaval not only with
the Trump administration but other
administrations who have not divested or
invested more in general that that's the
point that I'm getting at right okay but
I think that that's probably a broader
issue and we'd have to dig into it in
another episode but a very relevant
issue and I do appreciate you bringing
it up and thank you sincerely for the
phone call on that note we will wrap up
calls for the week go to a break and
then get to other stuff after the break